so what we're going to talk about today
is a new way to use shiny that we at our
students I'm agog it's and shiny gadgets
are a tool that you as an art developer
can use yourself or give to other our
developers they're a way to apply the
interactivity that shiny provides to a
new set of users people who program and
to begin this let's let's talk about
what a gadget is in contrast to what a
shiny app is I noticed from the poll
that about 1/3 of the people here
haven't you shiny so I'm actually gonna
spend a little more time talking about
shiny than I thought I would and that
that's the sort of great feedback that
uh I'm glad the polls can provide for us
if you do shiny or if you have a new
shiny before China is an R package that
allows you to create web apps with our
in the use case for shiny would be that
you have some sort of data or simulation
or model that you want to fit using our
I was really good for that but you want
to make it available to people who might
not have our might not know how to code
in our and you might just want to get to
easily and do the things they could do
like type on a keyboard or click their
mouse to control what happens yeah and
that's what shine does it builds a web
app from are your users get to visit
that app over a network the web app is
essentially a web page so any network
that can serve up a web page you can put
the app on and viewers can look at it
you can also keep your web apps local
and just look at them on your own
computer but the idea behind shiny is
your packaging your results in a way
that's someone who doesn't know are can
access easily and use easily and they if
you are completely unfamiliar with shiny
which I doubt is the case but if you've
never even heard of shiny before you
could go to the are su com website we
have a showcase of shiny apps there
that's you could play with and get a
sense of what shiny does so that was
them the motive for creating the shiny
package it's a very very popular package
when we're going to talk about today is
a way to use this package to do
something a little different instead of
creating a web app that you then serve
over a network to people who don't have
our and aren't interested in using our
you can use shiny to create an
interactive tool that
is loaded locally and in our users our
session and that they can use to do
interactive things we're calling these
tools that stay in your our session
shiny gadgets and I have prepared a demo
of a shiny gadget to make it you know
clear what we're talking about so this
is my art studio session you see I have
some scripts loaded up here and you know
there's some files in my directory these
are the files that I'll be putting on
github after the webinar and the first
file here is called get password it
loads a couple libraries including the
loads a couple packages including the
shiny package and then defines a
function called get password and if I
were to source this that function would
be defined and we can see over here my
environment it now exists get password
and if I wanted to run that function I
could do so and this function is unique
because what it does when you run it is
it calls a shiny app or I'm gonna call
it shiny gadget so here I'm running the
function and it opens this window this
window is a shiny app or tried and
gadget it has a field here that I could
type in it has some buttons that I can
click and this is right here in my local
our studio session the idea behind this
particular gadget is I could type in a
password here so let me type in a
password
you can't see it it's a password field
but then when I'm done using this gadget
I can click the done button and the
gadget will return what I've typed to my
our studio session or my our session so
I click done then we see down here at
the command line this is the password
typed in hello world and it's returned
right to the our environment that I
called get password from now in this
case that is called get password from
the top level but you know in our you
can call a function from another
function you can save the results to a
variable and so on so I can use get
password inside other our code when that
code gets to get password it will launch
the shiny gadget the user can type in
their password with the gadget I could
arrange to have that saved and then used
by the function that called get password
perhaps the login to a database or
whatnot
and what I would have achieved is
an interactive way for my users to type
in passwords required by the code that
they're running not just that this this
format typing in passwords here has some
advantages because the actual password
to connect to the database or do
whatever I'm going to do with that
password doesn't need to be hard-coded
into my code so I can share this code on
github and not worry about security
issues when the codes run that's when
the password will be typed in and so on
but the gadget aspect of this is it is a
function that calls a shiny app locally
and then once your user uses a shiny app
the shiny half passes values back to the
function that called it or the our
environment that called it that your
code can then go on and use so if we
compare that to shiny apps as you may
have used them in the past you can say a
gadgets use more in line with other
types of programming it's part of the
programming process for the user
we're showing you how to use only to
communicate results or to make
simulations or models accessible to a
wider audience gadgets are run in your
local our session there go past results
back into that our session where shiny
apps are designed to be self-contained
and to run on a network later when you
the our developer aren't keeping an eye
on things and then shiny gadgets are
invoked from functions they're always
called by in our function and then they
appear where as shiny apps are deployed
on a server and they sort of wait there
on the server until someone visits a web
address and then the server loads up the
app and the person is to see it when
they want to see so if you were to think
of the main difference between shiny
gadgets and shiny apps shiny gadgets are
much more for the our developer wears
shiny apps are much more for your
audience
in fact you could say those shiny and
gadgets are for data scientists and
they're shining outside for you know we
could be nice and call the people who's
a decision makers but maybe they're just
the people you want to communicate your
results to in other words shiny gadgets
giving you a chance to be like in the
1980s we had this Hair Club for Men
we're gonna use a shiny gadget you're
not just a shiny developer but you're
also a shiny client the potential
for this this interface was shiny is
pretty large you could just use your
imagination to imagine things that you
do with code that actually isn't very
easy to do in an iterative code of
fashion but then if you made that
interactive with the shiny gadget you
could do it much more quickly or your
users could do it more quickly so think
of things like cleaning data and
checking for outliers or filtering data
or just picking nice colors for your
graphs that are a little hard to do at
the command line but you could do easily
with the shiny gadget and by putting
that gadget into your code you make that
more a part of your reproducible
workflow even though it is something
that you're kind of doing spontaneously
on the fly all right so the gadget that
I showed you guys was called get
password it looked sort of like this and
I'm going to use it as a quick run
through what you need to know to make
your own shiny gadgets there are three
essential features for every gadget we
look at them quickly to get password and
then all I'll show you a more complex
gadget that allows that will last go
into the details but the way to think of
these features is gadgets are used in
the context of a programming workflow if
you want to interrupt that workflow and
get into a gadget then come back into
that workflow with the results of the
gadget we're going to first need to
create a way to access the gadget and
that's going to be by writing a function
that calls the gadget so here forget
password that function let's get
password that's pretty simple to do I'll
show you how to do it but it's just
writing a function next you need to
actually create the gadget experience
that your user gets this is similar to
any shiny app where you lay out a UI but
we've created a new package that can
help you make gadgets specifically
because gadgets are a little different
than other shiny apps and we'll show you
I'll show you what that means in a
second then finally after your user has
used the gadget you'll want to have a
way to take what they have input into
the gadget and put it back into your
programming workflow where it can then
be used by other functions and we'll do
that with a function called stop app and
we'll look at that as well if we were to
scan quickly the code for a get password
you can see all these things showing up
there I
password is a function I saved as a
function I defined as a function and I
invoked it by calling the function the
UI of this shiny app is made with with
these new functions that you might not
recognize if your shiny developer
because it comes from the mini UI
package and then I'm using the special
function called stop app to handle what
I want the app to do when the user
closes the app and this is the step
where the input has been given to the
app will get passed back to the code
that called the via so to illustrate
these things and they illustrate some of
the options and flexibility you have
around them I'm a more sophisticated app
which I will save in the github
repository in our script brush on your
score cachito are now have it open in my
art studio session right here
music code that makes the app let's
first try out the app to see what it
does so I'm running pick points which is
the function that saved the gadget it
opened over here my viewer window and
what you could see is this is a
scatterplot of the empty cars data set
with the weight variable on the x-axis
the mpg variable on the y-axis and that
comes from the way I called pick points
I said you know here's my data set
here's the x-axis here's the y-axis
variables and the reason this syntax
follows is because of how I wrote this
function now that I have the scatterplot
of points here I could use the gadget to
select actual data points in the data by
highlighting them with some brushing
using shinies interactive graphics
brushing capability then I could tell
the gadget with these buttons down here
I'll throw out these points I don't
really want to use them then they become
a light gray maybe I could throw out
some more points maybe I decide actually
do you want to use these two points so I
say you know put those points back into
play
or I could using this gadget make all
the points disappear so I can just
select the ones I want one at a time or
if I've gotten too far messed up I'll
just reset it all and start again what
happens when you click done for this
gadget is all the points that are still
highlighted
we'll be selected
well to be completely accurate the
gadgets go returned a vector of true and
falses that can be added to our dataset
empty cars every point that's
highlighted here in the gadget every
point I've selected will have it true
and every point that I haven't selected
will have a false so when I click done
we can see I get this vector back and if
I wanted to be more you know maybe
they're driving a point home if I want
to use this later I would save it to
something so now I'm going to vote the
gadget again I'll select a few points
again click done now this time I've
saved the results you can see selected
appears up here in my environment and I
could use this in code if I want to get
those actual points I could subset empty
cars with selected those are the points
that I ended up highlighting in that
gadget right so you can see what this
gadget does and hopefully you can see
you know this might actually be a useful
task so let's use the code in the gadget
to get a better sense of how we how we
made the catcher now we're gonna have to
think about those three steps how to
call or invoke the gadget from our
programming workflow what user
experience the user has inside the
gadget and then how to return results
back to the program the way that we call
a gadget as I said as I said earlier was
we save it as a function so here I'm
creating function called pick points I'm
literally just using our as function
function to do this and thank you you
know I'm closing the function since I'm
writing a function I could say any
arguments that I want for the function
so here I chose three arguments data x
and y and wherever these arguments of
course symbols appear in the body of the
function R will substitute in whatever
the user passes as data for data in that
place so here I have data this will be
the data set the user selects their
passing examples empty cars then same
for x and y now what's inside that
function is important first i'm creating
a UI object and then a server object if
you're new to shiny you should know that
these are the two objects that you have
to create to create a shiny app if
you've already creates on you apps than
you
recognize what I'm doing here is I'm
creating the UI for a shiny app then the
server logic for a shiny app for a
regular shiny app you would create these
things and save them and then you'd call
run app or a similar function to load
that app what we're doing here is we're
creating the objects and then we're
calling run gadget as the last line of
the function with those objects UI and
server what run gadget does is it
launches the gadget and it's the last
line of the function so the gadget is
what's returned from the function and
with this gadget itself is going to
return this the values that we tell it
to return letting someone clicks it done
so in terms of setting up your gadget
it's just like setup as a shiny app with
UI and server and then use run gadget
instead of run app to launch it that's
how we could invoke the gadget from the
programming workflow now let's look a
little at the user experience for this
gadget you can see that I'm loading the
packaged mini UI here for this gadget
the UI functions in the gadget are come
from mini UI and if we look at the mini
UI package you can see it's actually if
fairly small package so we developed
this to work alongside shiny for making
shiny gadgets and it has a few different
pieces of shiny layout that you can use
and the reason we thought it would be
important to develop a new package for
gadget layout versus a shiny op layout
is that most gadgets tend to be very
small the space that you use on the
screen when you make your gadget is
normally limited either your RC viewer
pane or you might have a pop-up window
or something but if you go back to the
slides if you picture you know the
dashboard over here on the Left we fit
all sorts of stuff in there and we we
conceivably have our users whole
computer screen to work with but then if
you look at the gadget which tries to
fit the same elements into the space
that a gadget would appear it's too
jumbled there's too much going on in
there and also there's elements of shiny
layout that try to resize things
automatically and create a fluid layout
that don't really apply to shiny gadgets
so many UI provides a way to fill
elements concisely into a small space
utilizing all the space available at the
same that's possible so everything fits
into your gadget the main function for
the menu I packages mini page takes the
pace place of fluid page and what it
does is it arranges to have a shiny
gadget that fills up the whole space
there is some extra CSS involved in
doing this and so the things I go into
mini page need to expect the sort of CSS
tweaking that many pages using to take
advantage of that space which means you
tend to only put it into your mini page
elements from the mini UI package like
mini tab panel knee taps trip and so on
however you want to have plots in your
gadget you want to have things that you
put in an almost shiny app these aren't
things designed specifically to use mini
UI the new I came about later so we do
have a mini content panel which acts as
a bridge between the things like a plot
output that you'll show in your UI and
the special
mini UI that takes advantage of the
space anything you put in mini content
panel will be taken to the space in an
appropriate way and that's your user
resizes in space or what not it will
work out well
so here's Papa outlet inside mini
content panel the other things in the UI
that you'll want to know about art
almost every gadget has a gadget title
bar at the top of the page this is a
very concise way to label the gadget so
here let's try and catch an example and
that automatically inserts a cancel
button a done button the cancel button
lets your user walk out of the gadget
should they not want to be there for
some reason it will return by default
and error a user error someone cancels
gadget the gadget doesn't really know
what to return to the program work foot
you can intervene and override what
happens when someone clicks to cancel by
the if you want the done button saves
it's an action button
it saves its result as input dollar sign
done and it's off to you to decide what
happens when someone clicks on done
that'll be the next thing we're talking
about we talked about a mini content
panel this is just how you put regular
input into your mini UI but then some
interesting things that you might use to
create features in your app or a mini
button block we've seen this with our
app and what it does is it gives you a
chance to add various buttons to the
bottom of your block these would be
action buttons you can control what they
do alternatively you could add a tab
strip panel this is similar to its have
panel in the shiny app where each of the
icons here at the bottom of the panel
when clicked opens up a new tab and the
content of the panel and I have an app
that demonstrates what this does the
back doors to you the tabs app uses a
mini tab strip panel to use mini texture
panel you have to at create mini tab
panels for each button in the app let me
source this and then just run this app
is all pure demo it doesn't really have
a logical function but when the
parameters button is clicked here we
have this
slider in the app we have our gadget
title bar at the top if we look at how
we're calling mini tab strip panel the
first tab panel contains its own mini
content panel that has the slider that
we see that has its own name parameters
that name appears down here and then
I've used the icon feature with the icon
function to add a sliders icon to appear
above the parameters make this a little
more visual since we're working in such
a small space you know this is a great
chance to take advantage of the phrase a
picture's worth a thousand words so
whenever we can make things graphical
here it can convey a lot of information
with the small amount of space
the next mini tab panels called
visualize we see here it has an area
chart icon the names of these icons
you might recognize there's coming from
font awesome if I click on visualize it
opens a new tab in the in the center
here now I have a graph and then map and
David do the same things data is
actually an HTML widget that we put
inside or app so there's there's some
other layer of interactivity here in
this app and then app demonstrates a
button block here it has a bunny lock
with a single button and the way I did
that because I added mini button block
into the tab panel for the map tab we
first had my content then I have my
button block I put an action button in
there it's called reset the last
part of well before we move on those are
you know just a few building blocks to
work with but you can combine them to
make you know sophisticated gadgets
there's really not so much more you want
to do to a gadget so this will take you
quite far and then if we go back to the
helping you you can see that there's
really not much else in this this minute
you I package the other functions your
handle there like the actual bars are
added by default to your gadget title
bar and if we stop that happen if we
were to look at gadget title bar you can
see that it does have some defaults that
are sorry using the tab completion you
can see it's it's calling these things
by default so you don't have to but if
you want to overwrite for example that
we're done and the done button then here
for the right argument you would
actually spell out the right argument
choose room type right so all that's
actually probably pretty familiar to you
especially if you're shiny developer I'm
going to take it for granted you've been
writing our functions and that you've
been creating UI in server because
that's what you do as a shiny developer
but this step might be new to everybody
involved then that's stopping an app and
returning values back out of the app you
can do this with a regular shiny app but
it really becomes essential when you use
a shiny gadget and it revolves around a
function called stop app and to take
advantage of stop app you you do need to
know how to use observe event which is a
shiny function for handling events the
way observe event works is you call this
in the server logic of your function so
just like you make a reactive expression
or set up your own server or
understatement we would set up an
observe event block there's two observer
that blocks one for each of the buttons
here and what observe event does is it
sets up an observer that watches a
reactive input every shiny gadget is
going to save inputs and cancel dollar
sign done as inputs for the two buttons
in the title bar unless you intervene
and name them something different so
these two observe events are going to
watch those buns and wait to see when
their values change action buttons have
a value an arbitrary value that
increments by
one time someone clicks the button so
when someone clicks up on that value
will change and these observe event
statements will notice that that has
changed the next part of the observe
event call is a code recipe that observe
invention run whenever the first value
changes so here when input thoughts I'm
done changes observe event is going to
run this code stop at what stop app does
is first it exits the app it closes the
app but then second it passes to the
environment that called the app anything
that you put as arguments for stop app
you will put multiple things so you can
create a list for stop after eater so
here let's assume that this app created
Val's dollar sign keep prop that's a
reactive expression perhaps a static
value stop app is going to return a non
reactive copy of it it will be the
current value of Val's dollars I'm cheap
when the app is closed when the user
clicks done so this is the trick for
delivering values collected by your app
so the code that called the app and then
if that code stored those values into an
object they can mainly be stored there
and you could proceed as a regular our
developer using that object and if we
look here in you know I brush gadget up
I you could see that I have set up down
here some observe event statements and
these observe event statements are
calling stop app so when someone clicks
done it's actually a stop the app and
return balance dollar sign keep which is
something I set up to dinky to be that
list of trues and falses that express
which bodies have been selected if
someone calls in with our sign campbell
canceled the knive arranged for this app
to just stop and return null instead of
returning in here and then I want to
take you into an application of shiny
gadgets and I'll get to that home but
there's one last thing I realized not
brushed over that I would like to to
draw your attention to
I think shiny gadgets are pretty simple
you know we've had half an hour and
we've covered almost everything that are
in them this is just the last topic you
may have noticed for example when I run
this app let's try with the code I guess
I did something
I it appears down here in the viewer
pane but when I ran the get password app
it appeared in a dialogue box which sort
of floated above the screen right there
and you can also arrange for your gadget
to appear in your users browser and the
way you do that is with the run gadget
function here when you call run gadget
by default it's going to create a gadget
that appears in our studio viewer pane
but you could set run gadget like I did
in the get password box we sent the
viewer argument of it to dialogue viewer
that would make the gadget appear in the
dialogue box like we saw before and you
could also alternately set this to
browser viewer dialog viewer needs a
title this box is going to pop up so we
need to give it a title to explain the
box but the other browser view doesn't
need that eye resource this get password
so now it's opening my browser here I
have to catch it in this this experience
and then if I wanted to in the viewer
box I would or I'd leave you were
playing because this is the default
password and here I have so these two
viewer functions are how you control
where the gadget pops up and this is
actually in the slide so you know if you
need a refresher on those you're back
here you can see where I meant to cover
this back for you alright so those are
gadgets what do you use your gadgets to
do and how you combine these pieces to
shape the user experiences it's really
up to you your experience in your
imagination but once you've created a
gadget there is something a little
further you can go a place you could go
further with the gadget that might be
interesting so I wanted to cover it here
in this webinar and what I'm talking
about is something that we're calling
our studio add-ins and the idea here is
with your gadget you you let your user
leave the programming workflow
temporarily like all
the function here be a password but you
could make that even more seamless by
giving them a GUI way to access your
gadget instead of calling a function we
can actually access the gadget from the
add-ins menu that is already in our
studio so if you have a recent version
of our studio definitely you know
version 1 or higher you will have this
add-ins box up here and what appears in
the drop down menu next to add-ins will
depend a little about what packages you
have and what not but this is a place
that collects add-ins
add-ins are essentially shiny gadgets
that have been built into the UI of our
Studio IDE so you can see I already have
get password listed here as an add-in
and if I were to click on that you would
open up this get password box and then
you know if I type in my password and
click done that'll get returned in this
case to the command line because of the
way this happens really if I wanted to
if this is something I found myself
doing in the law I could go to browse
add-ins and then keyboard shortcuts and
actually set up a keyboard shortcut so I
don't even have to click that and drop
down menu to use this add-in and you
know if usually keyboard shortcuts so on
so these are just ways to make it even
easier to access shiny gadgets when
you're using are the way to make an
add-in involves a package so add-ins are
shared through packages you create your
shrining gadget which you recall is
going to be an arm function you save
that our function in the package and
then you register that function as a
gadget by creating a file in this folder
in star studio add-ins DCF this is a
folder in your package and free to each
adding you and create you use fill out
these three fields name description
binding interactive and then when ever
user installs that package this atom
will be added to their list of add-ins
so let's take a look at how that that
can work we have this atom here it's get
password let's see if I could yeah let's
go save
it's Regional State this is one good pun
get up if you want to make a package
that some of you would probably got
nervous when I said you have to make a
package it's it's not that difficult to
make a package a package especially with
our studio we can make a package right
now to make the easiest way to make a
package is go to new project select a
new directory and then tell our student
you want that new directory to be in our
package I'll put on the desktop and I'll
give a package the clever name foo and
if you want to start with any functions
in your package you could do that by
going to the add button right here in
this pane and here I'm gonna have to get
password function to our package so I
added that now when I create the project
RC is going to open a new project but in
the directory of this project I have a
package structure in the our folder of
this package I have get password it's
already there I can open it up I think
it's not very well documented I'm not
sure if I need to export this or not but
go explore this function using oxygen
syntax plus should've done exit but to
make this an add-in what I need to do is
create that special file where I
registered as an added and the file
needs to exist in a specific place this
is where our Stu IDs go look for it it
needs to be in a new folder called inst
so I'm going to create that folder
inside that folder it needs to be a
folder called our studio during last by
memory I'll check to make sure it's
correct in our stars' to you add in
study see if ok and then inside our
studio I need to make a file called
add-ins so I'm going to start with a
text file here we're going to save this
file as it's like and starts to you I
start TCF and then I just need to
register my get password function here
and by accident slide showed the easiest
way would just be a copy and paste this
code I'm going to use the name get
password - you'll notice I already have
to get password in my drop down menu so
this will just differentiate it the
description that says what this does it
collects a password the binding is
important it's the name of the function
in this package that they get password
to add and should call when someone
selects it so when someone selects get
password - is going to call this
function get password it's just going to
run that function that function happens
to be a shiny gadget and this function
is interactive so on because it's a
gadget so I'm writing true there so now
I've created a package this literally is
packaged everything you need for
packages here if I want to build it in -
in fact the package that I could install
all of you go to build source package in
the build menu here we do have a webinar
about making packages in our studio by
the way so you can learn all this let's
just built a package and saved as food
zero point one point zero tar.gz on my
desktop now if I want to install it in
my our studio session go to install
instead of installing from cran install
from the file and I just need to find
that file which is right here it just
made it all right so it's installing
that package it's not very well document
package but there then now get password
to is in my add-ins list okay so with
that that's you know we create this
add-in in like 10 minutes that's how
easy it is to create an add-in and
anyone who gets this package should I
put on crayon or wherever they can
instantly have access to those add-ins
just by installing the package all right
if you want some ideas about building
add-ins there's two packages that
contain add-ins ones called add-in
examples that's on github in the our
studio account but if you google for it
you'll find it once called had Ladin
those are some add-ins that Hadley
Wickham created that's on github and his
github account but if you google have
lab and you can find it
and then there's a package called our
studio API this doesn't contain add-ins
but if you weren't getting business of
creating add-ins this is a package
you'll probably want to know about
because it provides our functions that
allow you to control the our studio ide
so you could for example open a file or
change the text inside of a file using
functions in our studio API when you
combine that with an ad and that's that
could be a very useful thing to do
alright so to conclude I to make it
shiny gadget just remember you can save
it as a function use library use package
mini UI to create the user interface and
then you stop app along with an observer
vent statement to return values back to
whatever function called your gadget so
thank you for paying attention and then
the material that I presents today is
encapsulated in three articles on
various our studio websites I put them
all right here the first talks about
gadgets the second talks about mini UI
and the last one talks about creating
our studio add-ins in addition to these
resources we'll put these slides and
recording of the webinar up on our
website within 48 hours so at this point
I'll take some questions here so the
first question is can you please
describe how gadgets will work with our
steel Connect I'm assuming it will be
identical to the way they work with
shiny
well gadgets are invoked from your code
so a gadgets not going to appear unless
first someone runs a function or some
code runs a function that invokes the
gadget or a second someone goes into the
adding menu and opens an add-in because
you've packaged the gadget as an add-in
so if you're using our studio konnekt to
to run code and you can expect your
gadgets to be invoked as a code strong
but I don't I can't really visualize at
the moment how that process would work
or snoo connects more designed for
communicating things that are already
deployed so that's very much the first
shiny app user case you deploy the app
so you don't really have to manage it it
takes care of itself at the moment
someone visit with our student that
moment will be
by our CEO connect sending them the app
at a certain time we're updating the
audience I think to someone else so I
don't know if that made things more
clear but that's that's how I think that
will work out
yeah I've transferred gadget in apps
several times easy do well every gadget
I mean the way I think about every shiny
gadget is an app not every shiny app is
a gadget and when you're using functions
like stop app to control your gadget
becomes very clear that your gadget is
now so I hope that has never incorrect
even though I might be an imprecise by
transposing catch in app I apologize
about that Bernard what happens if you
use run app at the bottom instead of fun
gadget do you get a shiny app instead
that's a good question I think
especially on education you will
experience behavior that you want to
steer clear of a run gadget gives you
the freedom to open your your shiny app
as a dialog box or in the pane or the
browser which obviously run app to us as
well but if you're using gadgets stick
with run gadget there's a reason we
create a separate function and you
shouldn't try to mix the two hi I'm new
to our is a shiny app gadget only
applicable when we use our Stewie or
some part of our language features both
shiny and shiny gadgets our idea
agnostic they're part of our you can
create them with or without using our
stew you ID and you can give them to
people to use even if those people are
not using our studio ide since we make
our studio ID and you also make shiny
we've we've been able to really
integrate them well with our studio and
our hope is that our students it easier
for you to treat these things but you do
not need to use our studio they're
completely disconnected how easy fast is
it to confer to pick a chit into a shiny
app if needed it's very simple just
unwrap it take the UI and server that
you create in your function body and to
find them outside the function body if
you're relying on parameters of the
function and supply things make sure
that that's your UI and server can stand
on their own
and then just replace run gadget with
run app but what's inside that function
is essentially a shiny app so it's very
easy to take it move it outside of the
function and have your shiny app also
it's very easy to do the opposite to
take an existing app and repackage it
that's a catch it the things you want to
work out for those is how the layout
looks when you go back and forth by the
way any shiny app can use the mini UI
functions within the app if you think
that they're better for your particular
app mini UI works for all running apps
can you comment on a comparison of a
shiny gadget in a shiny module that's a
good question because they both are
extensions of shiny in a way a shiny
gadget is a complete shiny app the shiny
module is not a complete shiny app it's
a part of a shiny app that's composable
so if you find yourself doing the same
thing many times across apps or even
within an app a shiny module would be a
way to write all that code once and then
reuse it multiple places it's sort of
like the function equivalent for shiny
apps in our if you're running the same
code multiple times you'd save it as a
function then you call that function
multiple times in shiny if you're doing
the same thing multiple times you save
as a module and call that module but
modules are not designed to be a
self-contained shiny app on their own
you always have to call them from within
the context of a larger shiny app that
you know finishes the packaging of that
app it's not true is shiny gadgets shiny
gadgets do exist on their own they're
self-contained so the two ideas are
actually sort of orthogonal to each
other we have a webinar and training
modules if you'd like to learn more
about shiny modules can gadgets be
include in shiny apps I think this is
kind of goes back to the shiny modules
idea a gadget is an app of its own it's
a self-contained app so you wouldn't put
it inside of another app whereas a shiny
module is shiny coding functionality
that is designed to be called from a
parent Apple our trap of some sort so no
I wouldn't put a gadget inside a shiny
app but here's a variation of that
question that might have some more
insight provides more insight can you
use gadgets within deployed
any apps I you can have your shiny apps
call functions and functions that are
called can call gadgets so you could
certainly try it out I haven't tried
that out and I don't know what you
should expect should you do that
I suspect that your shiny apps deployed
by a server that's running are in the
backend and if you have a trigger code
that launches a gadget I wouldn't be
surprised if that gadgets launched on
the server and its local our session so
your user never sees it but again I'm
just guessing here I have never tried
that out myself
I don't think that's really a use case
we have in mind each gadget has its own
surface design or what will you create
the UI that you want your gadget to have
using those many UI components whatever
you store to that UI object will
determine what the gadget looks like so
that's the surface design can you
comment on the benefits and drawbacks of
brush up compared to two digraphs I'm
not very familiar with digraphs so no I
don't think I can but if that is a
package that someone developed to do
something specific it's probably better
than this brush app which really is a
trivial app that we just designed to to
show off the different features of
gadgets then one more question and then
I'll turn it back over to bill the
question is I'm building a supply chain
simulation with the object oriented our
would be possible to use gadgets provide
a user interface for setting parameters
and controlling several pots except so
this questions a bit specific but this
sounds like the use case for a shiny app
gadgets are only for people who are
already in our session than writing code
at the command line
shiny apps give you the chance to to
curate your users experience so they
don't have to interact with our at all
and you can certainly provide a portal
to your simulation using the shiny app
that's what's meant to do so I'd
recommend just using a shiny app for
that